in this video and over the next few
videos i'm going to teach you all a few
special tricks to solve percentage
problems
let's look at the first trick 40 of 50
this is equal to 40 over 100 multiplied
by 50. by solving this we get the answer
as 20. this was just a basic method okay
say we have 60 of 40 how do we solve
this quickly if we use the traditional
way then we may take some time so here
we will use decimal technique 60 is 0.6
so we will write this as 0.6 multiplied
by 40 so we get six multiplied by four
which is twenty four so you got the
answer really easily and quickly another
trick that can be used here is called
the remove two zeros trick we remove the
two zeros and multiply six with four to
get twenty four similarly in the first
problem we get 4 times 5 which is 20. so
if you have to find 30 of 1200 then we
remove the two zeros and get 30 times 12
which is 360.
similarly what is 40 of 35 we can use
the decimal technique here 40 is 0.4 and
what is 0.4 multiplied by 35 35
multiplied by 4 is 140 and because we
have a decimal point here we put a
decimal point here we get the answer as
14.0 or 14. so 40 of 35 is 14. using the
decimal technique can you tell me the
answer to 80 of 60 in the comment
section